hey everyone welcome welcome welcome in
to Market takes uh we are starting a
little bit late today had to get over
some technical difficulties I appreciate
y'all being patient with me I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me I appreciate
that I never forget about it so
apologies for our late start but let's
jump into it this week we have a big
week earning season has already kicked
into full swing so I'm gonna be telling
you about that but also the three most
important things that you need to be
watching out for this week not all of
them are earnings reports but some of
them are listen we've got the retail
sales report that's coming out tomorrow
hope you'll be with us right here 10 a.m
on Market takes we'll be breaking that
down that comes out tomorrow morning we
also have the leading economic
indicators report that's coming out on
Thursday and earnings season we got
kicked off with the banks last week this
week we've got Tesla United Netflix
Johnson and Johnson Capital One Goldman
Sachs Bank of America Morgan Stanley and
much much more we'll tell you what you
need to watch and what to watch out for
in those earnings reports so let's start
off talking to you about retail sales
and what we can expect from the retail
sales report for June that's coming out
a little later this month first things
first want to throw up here on your
screen the latest numbers that we've
seen from the retail sales report and as
you see there some of those numbers are
going negative you see really for the
past seven months we've seen negative
reports on that on that retail sales
number so we have seen over the past
couple months a pick back up like we saw
in January and a reversal of that early
Trend it seemed like okay the trend was
just going to be negative going forward
but the last couple months we have seen
positive numbers and economists are
predicting that we will see an increase
of 0.5 percent month over month that
would be the biggest increase we'd seen
since that January number that we got in
February that you see there that big
pickup so economists are expecting
retail sales to start Rising again and
this chart is illustrating
that we really didn't break away from
that Trend that we had seen of retail
sales being negative folks not buy and
staying home they're clearly coming out
and going shopping again as we look
inside the report it's going to be
interesting though as retail sales pick
back up we're gonna have to dig into the
details so how hot are the services
components bars restaurants uh attorneys
all those things Barbers things like
that where you're getting a service
performed is that hot because that's
what's really picking up and pushing
inflation higher and that's the fed's
going to be watching out for so you are
going to watch that want to watch out
for that as well and are they slowing
Goods prices have been slowing we've
seen energy gasoline prices or as prices
at gas stations going down so does that
continue and what is really going to be
the key is that Services component June
will be the last month of the second
quarter so this could have a big impact
on earnings expectations as well next
thing I want to talk about is the
leading economic indicators or the index
of leading economic indicators let's put
a chart right up here on your screen
what we've seen from that here's why
this is a big deal as you see on the
right of your screen we have been
substantially and significantly negative
and every time that the leading economic
index has been this low we've had a
recession so you see those those light
gray bars there on your chart those are
recessions and every time that we get to
this level we are right now when you see
the decline we have a recession and this
chart really just again illustrates that
historical theme that we have seen over
time leading economic indicators are
things like the S P 500 but also the
interest rate the 10-year treasury minus
the FED funds rate credit indexes they
also look at things like business
surveys ISM and uh S P 500 or the S P
excuse me Global index of service or
purchasing managers uh manufacturers new
orders how the manufacturing industry
doing things like that and those tell us
about the economic indicators those are
indicators of what's going on in the
economy it's been a long-term accurate
recession indicator for a long time and
it is strongly pointing towards
recession right now other thing listen
it's earnings season and what I want to
throw up here on your screen right now
is what we've seen from the S P 500
stock index and clear really one part of
the uh the Lei that has been moving
higher especially in recent months you
see they're really just the stock market
taking off over the last couple months
that's a six-month chart going back to
uh March and I'm sorry this is a three
month chart just going back there
towards March and you've seen really a
big pickup going on in the stock market
and especially over the last couple
months uh that just illustrating again
the bullish sentiment that we are seeing
from Wall Street on those investor sides
but businesses really have not continued
to do that so we need to hear from them
this week in terms of that bullish
sentiment so analysts are predicting
that we will have the biggest earnings
decline in three years but they also
predict the S P 500 will go up another
nine percent over the next year those
two things really don't go together
especially when the FED has interest
rates high like they do right now so
what do we got this week we've got Tesla
listen Tesla's up 160 percent so far
this year uh year to date is that going
to continue last earnings or last
quarter the earnings were not so great
we saw net income down 25 four percent
and also Tesla launched a bit of a price
war in the electric vehicle space so
we're going to see just how that's going
for Tesla we've also got Netflix coming
out this week how did that crack down on
password sharing go you guys have
probably heard about that if you haven't
experienced it yourself that was
supposed to deliver a lot of new signups
and it's first you know when they first
announced this back at the end of May we
saw a blog post from antenna uh it's the
service writer and they chart things
like online signups they said Netflix
got a hundred thousand daily new signups
on May 26 and 27th so we'll see we'll
find out in the earnings report if that
delivered you know there were a lot of
big promises made predictions of 1.3
billion dollars in profit 3.4 growth
we'll see if they actually delivered on
those United Airlines another one we
will get this week uh the stock really
has not ever recovered from those covid
or from that big covid downturn stock
has picked back up a little bit but
we're still hovering in there how does
this season right now this summer travel
season is that going to get United back
on track and are we going to see data
that they really have gotten back on
track and are able to make money off of
the summer travel season how much of
those canceled flights hurt the airline
and are they able to keep charging these
high airfares we have seen in the CPI
inflation data that airfare prices have
been down across the board so how does
United deal with that we heard from
Delta last week Capital One Bank of
America Goldman and Morgan Stanley are
all out this week they're going to tell
us a lot about the health of the
consumer but a lot more about businesses
or businesses bullish's sentiment
picking up are they making those deals
mergers and Acquisitions are they
investing things like that we don't know
when we're going to find out you know
this week when we hear from those
companies Goldman is going to be big
Morgan Stanley is also going to tell us
about those wealthy High net wealth High
net worth excuse me individuals all that
Capital One and B of A are going to tell
us a lot about the consumer how much are
they putting aside for loan loss
provisions and things like that debit
card versus credit card spending we know
credit card spending picked up huge for
for JPMorgan Chase as well as uh
ourselves as well as Wells Fargo that's
what we found out last week so what's
going on with Capital One and Bank of
America is what we'll find out this week
listen that's going to do it for us here
on Market takes I appreciate you tuning
in be sure and check back with us
tomorrow morning 10 a.m We will be here
unpacking the retail sales report
tomorrow morning so if you'll stick with
us and we'll do it again tomorrow
morning I hope to see you there on
Market takes